what were those bugs those were graphics
row bugs are there bugs in version 12 or
are they bugs in in existing versions
it's hard for me to say exactly because
I don't think I had all the functions
that you were you were using some ragged
number something or other there's a
function you don't have let me send it
to you okay um
please believe yeah they're functions
that should be in the function
repository I don't think I was using
that ragged what's it plot but the basic
point here is graphics row what I was
looking at was a graphics row of
different shaped objects right right
they weren't stretching vertically
that's correct which is wrong right
graphics row should have so let's so
let's generate if I just say graphics of
rectangle and then aspect ratio
let's say arrow random real let's say
which we say 0.122
for let's say um extreme but not so much
so okay so let's say five of those okay
so now let's say graphics row of that
okay that's just wrong isn't it I mean
isn't that why is that why is it leaving
extra space there and this is a
prototype build correct no this is the
ahead branch but let's try I mean let's
look here at the regular version version
11.3 behavior well no I mean that is the
11.3 behavior because it's still in
Prudhoe okay well okay so let's look at
this so that that's just wrong it's not
what the documentation says it should do
because if you look at what Rho does
here right see it's it's tight it
doesn't have that equalization at all
okay what I'm saying mmm-hmm I
completely agree that you know and
graphics Rho is supposed to match
Heights now it could have an option that
to not match Heights but right now it's
some now is there a prototype is it
different in the prototype build so yeah
probably issues messages yeah and it
gives you something that's taller if
it's not I think it's still not matching
Heights which going into so that's wrong
right so okay hold on
oops what's going on here it froze and
sign in let's see this prototype um
let's just try this here okay but let's
just make sure we understand agree on
what it should be doing right
okay so first point like row I believe
it should be tight horizontally yes okay
or at least relatively tight perhaps not
absolutely tight well I think it should
do what Roe does that as the think it
has a second argument doesn't it that is
gives the spacing information right and
graphics Roe has an option that does
this know what graphics row should
behave just like let's back up a second
row has nothing to do with grids no I
understand row look this has a spacing
here right that's what that's exciting
but that's what it should be doing okay
so this is okay it tells you how often I
look at the usage statement well because
it also has that spacings option
horizontal and
vertical spacings that's probably a
documentation bug because that's really
for a grid that price shouldn't be there
for graphics row okay
but the thing that we're not dealing
with here right is there are two cases
one um let's see it doesn't really say
here what okay so the idea that it's
equalizing horizontal size is just
completely wrong there is an option to
grid to do that which I think we could
support here I think it's some kind of
equal sizes option well I mean graphics
grid attempts to do this already where
it tries to match the aspect ratios to
things I don't necessarily does it well
okay
what is the option to grid which this
doesn't appear to have okay so here
let's take a look at what this does if
we say graphics grid of list and then
percent eleven same thing okay mm-hmm it
would be very surprised if they weren't
okay so now the question is
I mean there's just a lot of stuff
that's wrong here I mean if I you know
I'm happy to change graphics grid well
it could break things I mean that's the
thing is okay so so we need to actually
be careful and do this design carefully
I think good but we're not really
dramatic we're not really doing that
development now Steven well we need to
fix the bugs here we need to fix these
bugs without question there no but what
I'm saying is that if it has a long tail
that itself means a problem I understand
but we need to try to fix the existing
bugs so we need to understand what it
should be doing right and when was the
bug introduced if I haven't a clue Oh
probably version six but then it's by
design
look what's doing is is wrong and it
needs to be fixed okay but then it was
never correct look what is this how did
it manage to get that shape there see
what I'm saying how did it managed to
expand that aspect ratio it even says in
the documentation that the things are
independently resizable right so that
thing see that bounding box see that how
did it go from that bound we even know
who did this to that bounding box yes no
who developed this yes where there's a
Kovas Kobe though no that was that was
graphics that was graphics grid that was
a different thing no no no no that was a
fix rows a special case of graphics grid
you
it wasn't supposed to be I mean I
remember that discussion
I remember and in some bizarre deja vu
because I can't remember and he you know
I remember having but he won't scold us
working with you Steven is that correct
the I guess the graphics grid
optimization code yes but not this not
graphics row graphics rows should have
been fixed separately because graphics
row does not have the same issues as
graphics grid if that was the intention
then it was lost at some point I don't
think I was ever aware of it okay well
let's go through what it should do
okay happily okay so graphics row
obviously doesn't have the same issues
as graphics grid graphics grid is trying
to tightly pack so if we take let's go
ahead and do this let's go ahead and
take an example of what this is trying
to do okay so um let's say we make a
five by five array here whoops that's
not what I want to do I want to say
comma 5 comma 5 there okay now I want to
say graphics grid of that okay now what
that did in fact not completely stupidly
here is solved the 2-way constraint
problem do you see what I'm saying Roger
you see what I'm saying yeah it's just
max us out in every dimension no that's
not correct no because these could be of
any size I know but but they it skills
until it hits an edge yeah it's it takes
two max height for each row you know I
think there's a more complicated issue
because I think what this is doing no
set frame goes to all
in each of those graph no no just on
graphics grid that I'm sure would be
wrecked II you know what the heck
happened there oh I see so one of the
issues here is that the width isn't the
same necessarily for all of them
right oh it is there there it's it's
making are those identical or not what
was that changed it just happened well
he has the random inside the thing so
every time you reevaluate so what I'm
surprised by is why that last column
isn't narrower see what I'm saying yes
because I'm pretty sure we we had that
so that means it's not per column taking
the max width well I thought that it was
I'm very confused by this I thought that
there is an option to grid which is an
equalization option said an item size
somehow well here look there is a why
does this that's a bug in this version
it's reported okay so there is an option
um what is it called I thought there was
an option
that was called something like equal
sizes or some such other thing it's not
ringing any bells to me that determines
whether a grid is forced to have it as
whether it's whether it's basically
forced to do this or not get what I'm
saying because I think a grid here if we
um let's let's give these image size
well that's not going to help as image
size it's an item size I think ah that
that okay so let's see I see width and
height of each item that's what I'm
thinking of make all items the same
width and height that's the point right
so this so the question is how item size
works in graphic
spread okay so item aspect ratio is
automatic
yeah I think item size support for
graphics grid is you know really what we
want and once that's implemented then we
have the control over you know to what
extent things are allowed to stretch
right but the default I think should be
that they are of equal height in a
graphics row and of equal width and a
graphics column okay okay um alright so
okay so I'm gonna let you ponder that
and come back with issues about it fair
enough
sounds good okay so let's go back now to
the to your list plot list line plot
options here right and we know about the
frame yeah right okay so what we talking
about last time we're talking among
other things about the the labeling and
where that goes right and this is where
I think we want Jeremy okay it's Jeremy
here it should be get a ball okay yeah
by the way we have a comment from our
live stream here about a case that being
claimed to be broken okay so let's take
a look at this so fails to tell me the
optimal size of graphics within sets oh
wow well yeah
wow that's pretty bad I mean is that the
same problem or is that a different
problem that is I think a different
problem
and that is I mean I think that's a
problem where it has trouble determining
what the sizes reliably well but why are
good it should be fixable space hmm look
most of the most of the space here I
mean if I say here you know frame I'm
not gonna have a gutter between those
those things am i no I mean in that
right now what I mean is that sees the
legend it doesn't know aspect ratio is
it's different it's you see this white
space here something is fluffing out the
aspect ratio and it's the same problem
we're seeing here see wherever that went
when I clicked on that right the
bounding box that you get is a fluffed
out bounding box right as opposed to a
tight bounding box to the actual content
okay and right that's presumably what's
wrong now again in the you know
can I ask you a question no okay so if
you look at that last column of the
black-and-whites yep you know second
from the bottom is the widest rectangle
yep okay so so what you know depending
on the setting for item size yep you're
expecting that when you select that
rectangle you get an orange box that's
tight to that rectangle that's what I'm
expecting so if I copy paste let's take
a look at this see this is something
really bizarre let's say I copy that and
I copy it out
oh that's just friggin weird how could
that have happened what is it doing
I am deeply I mean so it mate I'm not
sure I mean it could be on how oh look
at that
so that thing which I didn't give it an
aspect ratio yes you did yes oh yes I
did I did I'm sorry I did yes I did
excuse me okay but so somehow this thing
here the selected graphic isn't what I
actually get out which is totally weird
I'm wondering if when you click on that
rectangle on the inside if it's showing
somehow the extent of the inset that
it's inside of that could be so so if
you click it once somehow okay so now
click it a couple more times ah you're
right but then when I copied it it
didn't copy the inset which is correct
you're right so the
is inside an insect right and it's
making sure that all the you know in
sets are the same width within that
column so that yeah which is probably
which is the correct thing to do for the
grid but is not the correct thing to do
for the row right I mean the rows in
sets all need the same height still but
well the row in sets aren't all the same
height that's the problem that we have
well no I mean they need to be yes right
and I suspect that they actually are all
the same height we've got a graphics row
here that's let's regenerate it that's
just so friggin weird
okay so that thing for some crazy reason
because it thought it was in a in a it
had some kind of atavistic notion of its
ancestors in the grid you know but it
thought it was in a grid somehow which
it obviously isn't right mm-hm
so that inset is incorrectly computed
for the it had a wide inset which just
shouldn't be there
right now but let's try to generate
again something which come on why are
these aspect ratios always okay so that
one this okay so that one again that one
has a an incorrect inset so we can drill
it and then we get down to that what
should happen here though I mean how
wide should a given item be before it
stops growing in width
yeah it's a good question it probably
needs a constraint on that right I think
I've placing you know code word it's
plus or minus you know a factor of ten
or something I'm not sure tennis I think
four is probably better okay but I agree
that that probably needs to be a
parameter in graphics row I I would
think that that should say I mean a spec
into item aspect ratio seems to be a
control that determines that and the
question is what the well you want
variable aspect ratio but maybe I'm max
but I mean can you open the notes
there's a completely useless but yes I
mean it could have an up to or something
like this yeah we're you know up to five
means 1/5 2/5 or something yeah yeah
interval what about interval
I mean interval this is what I was
thinking initially now I think that we
could that the default is interval 1/5
2/5 or something that that represents
you know adapt it within those bounds
all right okay okay let's let's review
this again but but I really would love
to see this fixed gosh this is I mean
that's a particular project I happen to
be doing right now which is full of
these graphics rows and I'm really kind
of shocked that they didn't work okay
okay so now we have the other things for
back let's go back to multi-panel plots
okay so if I change the aspect ratios
here can I do that if I say in these
aspect ratios aspect ratio automatic are
you running a prototype build first of
all let's use proof actually this we
just someone from our live stream just
pointed out another it looks the same
well they claim it's going to be more
horrifying still so let's just see makes
at Table five by five it's taking so
long
maybe it's the contour plots then it
shouldn't be doesn't look too exotic
maybe it's the other innovation in the
graphics grid probably hopefully not
this is really strange do you have the I
what the heck that is what what do we
have there so we have random plot labels
random axes and frames as
it makes us every it's really made to be
a non-uniform good stuff yes but the
problem is that it's obviously cutting
off the labels it is when is it legend
in plot is suspected if it didn't have
any legends it would look fine well but
the point is that the complaint here as
legends are being all randomly cut off I
don't know if we understand why that is
but I expect it's the same old problem
of not being able to know sizes that it
wasn't yes but that's a good bug case
thank you um okay let's go back over
here so if these are different what what
do these do if they're different aspect
ratios they normalize so so first of all
in this case this nine plot doesn't
allow for different aspect ratios and I
don't if I say aspect ratio automatic
it's got a different data remember
I mean so it has different data but it
doesn't you know this first version of
you know within list line plot doesn't
allow individual you know individual
address ability of options I understand
that but if I said aspect ratio to
automatic with that just would what
would it do for the individual panels
what aspect ratio would it assumed the
individual panels
well automatic has the concrete meaning
yeah so it's the same if you do
automatic for one if you plot them all
curves in the same plot automatic has a
meaning yeah okay so let's take a look
at what this does it's probably going to
be really you're not in your prototype
build the prototype build seems kind of
confused but anyway let's try yeah so
you should get like three really skinny
things stacked on top of each other whoa
locust all right let's try a concrete
aspect ratio why did you try it without
okay Gandhi okay so now you say
okay so I think you've got a plain Jane
bug there too automatic is yes but I
think what it should do is to use the
same automatic as if you plot them in
all in one frame he won the case we're
shipping now I agree with you yeah it
should look like three copies of that
one in me it's got to take the union of
all the points to determine the to
determine the because because the scales
have to agree yes take the union of the
points so if one of them was just down
in a corner tough luck it's all you'll
see right yep so in a in a future
iteration we might be able to do
something more elaborate where it's kind
of more like the variable width striping
of a.m.
what c'mon call it you know a Pinterest
type output um as opposed to this case
where they're all fixed you know they're
all the same width right what was the
interest comment well because because
that's an example where where the widths
are fixed but the heights are not AC
right and they and they don't form a
grid and actually we don't have
okay let's actually comment on that for
a second so do you say we're gonna look
at the interest you know we had this
long discussion of when do you allow for
individual controls you know when when
we take multiple data in a single plot
functions and when do you use show or
graphics grid and other means of
combining and I think that we put a
limit on how complicated we make the
option structure yeah you know and then
if you're if you're outside of that
range then you do them individually and
combine cuz then you have all the Flex I
just want to come back to the the quotes
Pinterest comment okay Jeremy we've used
in a bunch of websites and things we've
used that methodology haven't we we have
I I think multi-column would get you
there though so you could do multi
column of a list of graphics you know
for and you would basically get that
effect that it would be in
column-two not rose so what you're
saying is if I take whoops my gosh wow
this thing is really killing it
do I need to save this this file I've
got a screenshot of it and that inputs
in the chapter on Twitter anyway all
right I guess what you don't get is
you'd have to constrain the width
yourself okay so in this case here
you're saying here we could say um on
this we could say multi-column yeah but
you'd have to set a width
otherwise it's gonna be a mess dude
wants a list as input nuts oh yeah flat
under camp the air okay that is
officially not a satisfactory situation
because that didn't resize those images
right - I mean multi-column is still
constructing a grid
okay but I believe we need this
functionality and I don't think it
should be graphics grid and so what you
want here is you want to you know even
with columns that pack densely
vertically that's correct
knowing that there will be raggedness at
the bottom right can image collage does
it don't no I don't think so
so I mean we want both cases probably we
want the the horizontal case and the
vertical case the horizontal case is
brought with me the vertical case
probably more common yeah probably
alright so that if you can come up with
I mean I don't know what we call it we
call it graphics graphics multi-column
probably there's something involving
pack or I would say graphics Multi cone
because it is the multi column
functionality and they are but it's not
really the multi-column functionality I
mean cuz multi-column you know if you
you look inside that cell you know near
the top but almost certainly there's
going to be a grid box well in the case
of okay but I think conceptually okay
that would be my first take on it is
that it's a but that's essentially what
it is like graphics ro graphics column I
mean graphics multi column is the
natural way of doing it from graphics
column now okay what we can discuss this
separately but right um you know I think
that that's making the assumption that
graphics multi column is just add
something here to my list um okay
alright let's go back now to your to
this okay alright so now what are the
questions here so the question is you
know that alternating frame label
approach very exotic I don't think it's
that exciting well I mean so the thing
is is that you know it's hopefully
obvious the problem we're trying to
solve well it's the crashing of the end
points correct and there's sort of two
approaches to that one is we take an
alternating approach mm-hmm and the
other is try to avoid the endpoints also
instead of 0 to 20 we only put the tix
for a 5 understand or increasing the
gutter
Jeremy what do you think about this
alternating solution I don't like it at
all it just looks messy to me but I
understand the issue I just don't like
the way I think you should look at
something you know let's look at the 3
by 3 case
okay I mean by the way by the way by the
way an alternative to this approach
would be you know lose that yeah
and potentially lose this but you always
are keeping the global endpoints hmm
right right
so okay so in a case like this
okay first question is in a deep thin
with multi multiple multi Decker
creature should we be labeling the
things at the top as well as the bottom
sir so change your 5 20 to 25 20 and
column 2 to column 5
oops wrong front end again
right one I don't know I should give you
my toolbar what does that do is he
telling you a version number yeah among
other things that sounds useful put it
in the function repository it's a lot of
internal stuff well put it in the
internal function repository okay and
give it to me too because I'd like it um
okay
all right oh boy this is a pretty wild
creature
you
do you have an option where we could see
it crashing try setting frame tix goes
to all it's probably the best chances
getting it through
nope okay okay I just want to I just
want to understand this meeting
structure so the thing we're trying to
figure out here is the stuff about where
the tics go right are there other things
we need to figure out or not I think
that's the main thing okay so you've
done something with graphics grid here
is that correct right and so what that's
doing in that case is it's sort of
relying on making sure that all the
plots have the same amount of padding
okay and how much padding is that it
depends on you know so for the most part
it's determined by that bottom left one
in this case because it has the biggest
Layton's so it's looking at you know how
much padding does each plot have and
then making sure that things you know
sort of match that do you have a for
example when you're dealing with units
and things like that is that correctly
being factored into all of this it
should be I mean so the units you know
don't show up in you know the tick
labels at the moment you know they get
you know shown as access labels or I
understand I'm not wrecking you in the
multi column and multi-panel case today
where do they go top of the hole where
do they go in the framed multi-panel
case so it's probably in it if it's so
so so for like this plot that's gonna be
all the same
for every plot and so it'll go in you
know once per row once per column sort
of thing
Wow I don't remember off the top of my
head I mean so so like plot you know if
you have labels you know like I have a
label for this curve I have a label for
that curve sort of thing then recall
that they go at the top of each panel
right below the frame
can you show me an example so if you go
back over to yes you take you know a
simple you know like yeah yeah the three
first line plots sorry
the default plot sighs okay is there any
sense in having the default plot size
increase if you're doing a multi panel
plot just like I think for image and for
graph the default plot size increases
when you have more nodes or but when you
have more more content doesn't it
okay which certainly does for image so
if I say table I think it can only go
smaller I don't think he can never go
bigger image can be fairly big I think I
think image can get big to write and
Geographics is bigger by default okay so
I'm going to so I'm I'm making my case
again so if I say table here
buh-buh-buh-buh-byeeeee now let's say 1
point 5 to the N I might need to round
that um what the heck so those all came
out the same size I don't think that
the image size I think that's oh that's
not the image size sorry yeah there we
go right but if you go big then yeah it
gets big can you right-click on that
last one and set it to actual size just
to see if it's shrunk its it may
drunkard yeah that one was actual size
shrunk it well let's find out what it is
okay that seems about right but why
would why would it have gotten bigger in
the list let's let's try going 17 steps
that is odd I think that's a case for
shoddy by the way it's an interesting
example for the documentation I'm going
to send this who should I send this to
should I send this to shoddy sure um
I run it I wonder so images don't Auto
shrink inside lists then they do I
believe yes they do
yeah they absolutely do so something
happened here okay okay let's come back
to your so I'm what what do you say
about my possible suggestion of increase
in size when there's a multi panel plot
so crazy I think increasing the size is
fine I mean obviously we don't want to
keep the individual plots at their
normal size you know I think we're
absolutely not no no we might want I
mean a gradual increase is what I'm
talking about I mean I think my
preference would be for predictability
that you know so normal plots are like
360 wide that's you know a multi you
know if we have multiple columns that
they're allowed to be 500 or something
500 ish and whether it's two columns or
ten columns it's 500 ish yeah I mean
obviously if a 360 is that is the
default size for an a plot the the
minimum you know the minimum column
number is two so right I mean let's take
this let's just take this one as an
example
okay and
sighs and I was so slow as that okay so
now let's copy that and I don't know
what what we think would be more
reasonable but let's just try I mean to
my mind that's more reasonable and let's
see probably about 540 I'm only mildly
impressed that was 600 roughly that's a
ticks threw me off
how how wide is the default window can
you do a timeline plot of what yesterday
today so I believe that size at least at
the time we made it was just under the
widest that would fit in the
documentation so look I think the
multi-panel plot should go probably to
this you know 600 ish
Jeremy do you have comments on this no I
think that's good
I definitely bigger good right I mean so
the other thing is that it's going to I
mean I think it should also constrain
vertically sure you know if you have 5
rows yeah if this aspect ratio is
flipped around you don't want it to go
well I don't know what what happens with
a normal plot how does that constrain
vertically so a normal plot a normal
graphic the default image size is
whatever will fit within a 360 by 420
box 361 420 hi ok fine so let's scale
this the same way so it's 600 by a dish
yeah that sounds fine to me
um unless the default the default window
is way taller than 800 pixels right
assume it is if it doesn't we talk about
it again oh let me just measure it real
quick
okay just fault window here's just
around 900 pixels on my Mac alright okay
so fine so 800 is okay I think Johnny
you want to object no I think that okay
um okay all right so let's go back then
so the remaining issue here is what to
do with these labelings okay so first
question is do you have any control of
these labelings right now internally yes
exposed no I mean so at the moment I
could relatively easily you know drop to
zero and 20 could you try that and I
mean is it possible to do it in real
time now and show us what it like I'm
not gonna try and do it in real time
because I think you also have a three
o'clock meeting that's yeah okay but
puts together that and send out a screen
shot okay okay I like your idea of
keeping the very extreme zero and 20 I
think they'll be much more visually
obvious to people I mean I'm a little
concerned Jeremy can you comment on just
the amount of noise associated with
having all of those numbers on on the
sides of these plots taking
weed them out and only have a few well
no I'm saying okay so one possible
strategy would be a question is if this
is labeled this is labeled this is
labeled it's like it's numbers you know
the whole thing is is just drowning in
numbers I mean might it vary in this
case for version 12 the range is always
the same okay let me ask the question
actually somebody on the live stream is
asking about supporting multiple axes on
plots
that's another notch a 4-12 I understand
but I know it's relevant to this
discussion yes the design theory for
that we need design theory is that you
will get you know so if you have two
such things one will go on the left one
will go on the right right but is it
effectively a plot layout because it's
basically putting two curves to come to
plot layout is is is basically
superimposed right okay sure but there
are some issues you need to be able to
identify your access in your curve
together absolutely okay how many people
usually do that they do it in a stupid
way they just usually would color or you
can never even have a selector but but
often I see that with you know a blue
curve and a green curve or something but
they don't there's nothing in the plus
itself that I doubt of times people do
it badly you know they just have you
know like you say two different color
curves and and you kind of just one is
one of them is in BTUs and the other is
in feet or something right and you have
to sort of deduce which curve is which
yeah that's completely crazy do you have
a better idea well you can also style
them so the axis is styled the same way
to curve this but that's going to be
ridiculous to I mean well I mean whether
I mean you don't necessarily have to
style the entire axis I mean you could
have you know a little color swatch you
know at the bottom or so for example in
the place where you might have an access
label you have an access swatch or
something like that that's not crazy um
yeah
don't know that I've seen anybody do it
that way but I mean I think you're
shameless what's really nice watching
yeah but I've certainly seen this sort
of styling of axes and not necessarily
the labels but the the axes sure some -
what what are you thinking sorry what
what kind of speaking car I think in
color primarily Castillo yes or part of
the axis you know the ticks but you can
experiment with with variety of things
Tara the other thing that is you have a
sense of that I mean that just seems
incredibly ugly to have color ticks that
match the color of there because you
know you've got maybe a good six but the
axis I just think that's incredibly ugly
there are certainly cases where
generally speaking people have done
things where the label colors match the
the label I like that idea then you can
encode so what that's trying to leverage
is this you know an identification
legend it allows you to match two things
that are apart
right but I mean basically what that's
saying is if if you legend it or default
if you don't have a ledger if you don't
have a knack saying the axis place the
same role as a legend it's it's an
additional yes I get it I get it
so I think I mean what we're tentatively
saying is what we want is to have a
swatch of color that shows that this
axis is associated with this curve this
axis is so say with that curve and that
may very well work out well because
that's more subdued it's not as yeah
this extreme but I think we should
implement the other case to I think
might be you know showcase in a
presentation that's probably the better
way to go right is this Y axes only or
is this x axis and y axes and I'm gonna
bring the next question a multi parallel
plot that has multiple okay so
multi-panel plot could have the
situation that the right labeling is
different from the left labeling I think
eventually you're gonna get into
graphics grid where you sort of bundle
every you know what you're seeing here
are very efficient layouts once you
break stand I understand but I'm saying
that consider that case where everybody
has two curves on them
right a left curve in a right curve I'm
saying the rightmost you know ax
rightmost frame is labeled for the you
know you know the the right referencing
curve and the left for the leftmost
frame for the left referencing curve
maybe I mean probably possible but you
know at some points your specification
well that specification wouldn't be
what's happening there is that you're
superimposing the I mean you know plot
layout could be called double access
that would be one right so the question
is if you give three curves and the plot
layout is double access what do you do
basically what you have to do
well I mean I wouldn't call it double
access and what it would do is you would
get you know an extra access to the
right well no you get the frame are we
talking an access or a frame I mean you
would get an extra scale no to the axes
and frames are both scales that you
would have you know numbers on the left
frame numbers on the right frame and
then either to the left or the right you
would have another vertical line that I
you know identified you know what range
of numbers you're looking at for that
third curve okay well I'm not okay
our live stream points out this curves
could be spatially biased towards one
axis or at the other
that's an interesting case where there's
essentially overlap where there are
points that go to to the right where the
left curve the left referencing curve
doesn't have points
for high X values sure but there's a
question of what you want do you want
comparability or not do you want direct
visual comparability yeah you know
that's what you had in Houston right now
you have visual comparability if you
adapt and change two scales all the way
around you don't really you can have it
on a per row basis maybe or yeah but but
then you don't have visual comparability
you have to drill deeper you have to
parse deeper in the in the in the
dashboard
I get it I get it but at this point
about how you can end up with a
situation where if you have two curves I
mean I think what we have to do is
basically in the in the specification
it's like saying whether a curve goes
with the left axis or the right axis
okay
let's I think the thing to try I think
we should try this this thing where look
to my mind we should probably have some
named cases of these of these things and
we we want the you know just you know
okay we probably want the alternating
labels we probably want the pruned you
know the interior labels right now
there's another case I would argue so
I'm concerned that if you put all of the
numbers around this that it's going to
look stupid and for example do you put
the numbers in this a little inset
ething here you know for the pruned one
newer where we're not doing alternating
I would expect that one to get some
numbers some numbers no so whatever's on
the left or whatever's on the bottom
Jeremy do you think that when if we put
in so many numbers that it's just going
to look stupid it's hard to answer
right now they all match and maybe this
repetitive but as soon as the range and
all go
they all get a match German but they are
gonna match in this case graphics grid
has a ton of things where they cannot
match but it's it is a lot more sort of
conforming to do to make it look okay
right so in this case they will always
match
and um you know so I would like to
suggest an alternative okay my
alternative would be label only the
corners the outer corners somehow other
words just label
don't try to label every you know label
essentially a prototypical plot so for
instance I even might argue for labeling
this plot by the way these should have
ticks
there's no just again not have ticks um
you
okay and um so I I'm arguing for a case
where you essentially are labeling a
fiducial plot but nothing else and then
everything else you just assume you just
tick it so to speak that's right that's
a pretty decent idea this sort of very
minimal it's very minimal yeah um okay
so let's try these cases and and we can
give an option what would the option be
that I mean is it is it a plot layout
option or what is this I mean probably
my first approach on it would be a
method option okay fine that's probably
the right thing for right now okay we
have a few comments on the live stream
and then we need to wrap this meeting
yep um one comment is option display
access or show access as I hover a mouse
over the specific plot yes yes for sure
yeah right on hover you can absolutely
light up the access right exactly that's
part of everything for multi access to
that you want to be able to do that when
you hover over a curve the axis that's
relevant to that curve lights up sure
definitely but there are many
applications where people print the
thing where that isn't a possibility um
we also have an example here where
apparently there's trouble with graphics
grid and some performance issue so maybe
you can look at that okay the examples
in the chat I mean in those twitch yeah
yeah okay um okay thank you all very
much those those are paying attention to
live streams we have a live stream of
like game theory coming up soon um okay
see y'all soon see